inflation in the United States is now
officially at 8.5 percent it's likely
even in the teens if you account for The
Unofficial inflation rate but most
people don't understand what the hell
inflation is how does it work Sam
bankman freed the founder of FTX and a
multi-billionaire before the age of 30.
he hit a great thread on Twitter
explaining exactly what inflation is and
how it works here are some of those
exact tweets first he started out by
saying inflation is in the eye of the
beholder this isn't exactly what the
mainstream narrative includes then he
goes on to explain that yes inflation is
bad and as long as money goes up the
cost of goods goes up as well but if we
then look at his third tweet here what
we can see is that he describes that
ultimately inflation is getting at what
is the denominator how are you actually
going to hold the dollars constant he
says if you rename cents to Dollars and
dollars to 100 x dollars then of course
you've increased the money supply by a
hundred X things inflated 100x but
everyone has just as much bread or
whatever consumer good as before and so
a lot of inflation is merely the
manipulation of numbers without actually
changing the value or the quantity of
the physical things in our lives but if
we then go ahead and we take a look at
his next tweet well we can see is that
he says over the past few years money is
up about 40 percent and the actual goods
are up about 15 percent but does that
actually mean that there's a 25 increase
in the physical Goods no not at all
actually it may be the exact opposite if
we take a look he says that let's use
bread as the example there's probably
about five percent less bread in the
world today kovid created supply chain
issues and that made it harder to ship
bread around the world and then the
violent conflict in Ukraine literally
led to lighting Bread on fire and lots
and lots less production of Wheat and so
if the world has 40 more dollars and
five percent less bread why is the price
of bread only increased 15 percent
Sam then goes on to explain that that 15
increase directly comes from the idea
that money is up forty percent the price
of bread is up 15 and the amount of
bread is down five percent that means
the median dollars are only up about
five percent and so if we take a look
much of the money increase went to the
rich who can only consume so much bread
so much of that increase in money didn't
lead to an increase in the actual price
of goods but even money to the rich
leads to higher demand for things like
energy which in turn leads to more
expensive Brett and so regardless of
where the money goes whether it's to the
rich or the poor demand increases and if
demand increases for a finite amount of
goods the price has to go up in order
for everyone to be able to get it if we
then take a look Sam explains we really
have a few effects superimposed on each
other if you burn five percent of bread
due to war in covet it's about five
percent inflation that's bad but if you
print five percent of money for for
everyone it's five percent inflation as
well he claims that that's fine
inflation is just the flip side of
having more money now of course that is
based on the fact that everyone would
have to get five percent more money but
we've seen in inflation is that the
money goes to the rich people not to the
people who have no investable assets and
therefore different people in the
economy are actually affected
differently than if we continue with Sam
he says that if you print 17 and a half
percent money which goes to the rich
they spend it on investments there's no
inflation from that in terms of the
price of consumer goods but if you then
print another 17 and a half percent of
money and that goes to the rich but they
spent it on energy and other physical
Goods which makes bread more expensive
that's the bad type of inflation that
everyone's complaining about and so if
you simply give people money and they
invest it it's not an issue but if you
give people money and then they turn
around and they spend it on actual
consumable Goods the increases the price
and that is not evenly distributed in a
society then if we can continue we can
see here that Sam concludes you can't
increase the monetary Supply and expect
that to be free but by the same token
when inflation follows don't forget that
some people still have more money stock
splits aren't free money and they also
aren't pure dilution they're to the same
side of the coin they're perfectly
balanced this is a really interesting
way to look at this because Sam then
goes ahead and points out that sometimes
they're not perfectly balanced in the
end you want to know how good things are
look at the actual Goods we get in the
end do we have more or less of them and
how are they distributed kovid sucked
Warren Ukraine sucks so we have much
less stuff and then lastly and probably
most importantly Sam States piled on top
or a combination of inflation and
monetary Supply increases and a change
in monetary distribution just to confuse
things and so that's a great summary of
exactly what's happening in our world
right now is we have the debate basement
of currency we have the disruptions in
supply chain and instead of thinking
about inflation is good or inflation is
bad what you have to understand is that
the people who are most vulnerable in
our societies they're the ones who get
hurt the most by this because any level
of inflation any increase in the
monetary Supply doesn't go to them those
are the rich people and those rich
people they're not very good at sharing
and so ultimately the bottom 45 of
Americans with no investable assets
they're struggling right now they're
getting paid less at work than they used
to and also the cost of the goods they
buy on a daily weekly and monthly basis
are much much higher than just 8.5
percent a year ago and so ultimately
inflation is ravaging many many
Americans and even more people globally
we have to start to wrap our heads
around this we have to invest personal
finance education and we have to make
sure that people have the information
they need in order to preserve the
Financial Security of themselves and
their families moving forward hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time